Let's think of a case where two events are not
equally like look at this set of numbers
3 4 5 6 and 7 Suppose you have to choose one
random number from this set it can be any
one of the seven numbers What is the
probability of  Choosing an odd number to know this
first we need to find the odd numbers
in this set these four are odd you could have picked
any of the four odd numbers 1 3 5 and
7 and you could have chosen one number from ten seven
numbers so the  Probability will equal
4/7 four ways in which we can get an odd number
and that is the total possible number of outcomes Similarly what would be
the probability of
choosing an even number you can choose between two
or three possibilities  Out of
sane so the probability would be
3/7 so if you observe carefully the
probability of getting an odd number is
higher than the probability of getting an even
number in simple words it means that if you
pick any random number from ten sets the like  The
probability of getting an odd number is higher than the probability
of getting an even number so these events are not equally like
Numbers That Are Still Se And 0 Ba
Se Is 0 V
Se That Probability Is Zero And Impossible And What If You Ask
The Probability Of
Picking A Natural Number From The Seven Numbers
Any Number You Pick It Will Only Be A Natural
Number So There Are Seven  Ways In Which You Can
Pick A Natural Number And The Total Possibilities Are Also Say And This
Is
One We Say That The Probability Is 1 And
100% We Call This A Certain Event It Will
Certainly Happen If You Watch All The
Probabilities Videos I Would Say  It's
Certain That You Would Master This
[Music]
Topic